steel is steel you don't have steel you
don't have a country we want to build
our ships we want to build our planes we
want to build our military equipment
with steel with aluminum from our
country you don't want to pay tax bring
your plant to the USA there's no tax
we're negotiating now with China we're
in the midst of a big negotiation
I don't know that anything's gonna come
of it they have been very helpful
President Xi I have great respect for a
lot of respect but I don't know that
anything is going to come of that but
we're going to cut down the but the
deficits one way or the other President
Trump today pulling the trigger on what
he's talked about for a long time and
that is tariffs on imported steel and
aluminum despite some pushback from
people in his own party about this that
said there could be a lot of wiggle room
when push comes to shove on what exactly
happens with allies key allies who
export steel into the u.s. we're going
to start there as we wait for the
breaking news out of the White House on
South Korean North Korea let's bring in
our panel
Jonathan Swan national political
reporter for Axios Katie Pavlich news
editor at townhall.com
and Charles Lane an opinion writer for
The Washington Post
okay Katie you know it wasn't a surprise
it maybe was a surprise how it was
rolled out but the president has talked
about wanting to do this for quite some
time and the question is whether it's
going to be as big as they say this well
big as they say it is in terms of the
consequences which Republicans and the
Chamber of Commerce are warning about or
whether the president is going to water
down some of the things that he put on
the table initially and if you look at
the way that he's negotiated he tends to
do that but the language that he used
today in his initial opening line at the
White House during his event with the
steel workers behind him when he talked
about this being about flexibility and
cooperation with our true friends both
in terms of national security trade and
a military basis that says to me that he
is not just going to negotiate these
tariffs on a trade issue he's gonna
negotiate this new perspective of our
NATO allies still going to contribute
more money as he's talked about in the
past but for Republicans who have
criticized this it's not just that they
on principle oppose these tariffs which
they do based on the history
how terrorists have affected the economy
in this country they're also doing this
politically because if the tariffs do
take away all of the gains from tax
reform that Republicans have been able
to go back to their districts in an
election year and tout they can say that
they were against it from the beginning
and it's not necessarily their fault
because they had that distance from the
President on the issue but Jonathan
think about this I mean if it is as it's
starting to unfold here that each Ally
each country involved is going to
individually negotiate on some in some
way to avoid these tariffs on their
exports you could foresee that some of
those countries are going to take that
ball and run with it and maybe it
doesn't affect those big countries who
are exporting steel into the US well yes
that's the most from their perspective
the most optimistic scenario but just to
get you inside Trump's thinking here he
one of the big breakthroughs in his own
mind because he didn't want to do any
exceptions all along for 30 months he
was saying you know if I give Canada
exception then I get a call from Japan
and then I have to give them so he
didn't wanna do anything he wants to do
blanket global tax but he had a
conversation with Justin Trudeau the
Canadian leader and he became convinced
that he could get a better deal on NAFTA
because Canada sells so much steel and
so much aluminium makes us will Mexico
much less actually it's really about
Canada much more than Mexico even though
they are exempt Canada is the big one
who sells steel and aluminum and so
Trump believes he's going to get a
better deal on that but what if he
doesn't he could easily go flip back in
the other direction so I know we're all
saying he's going to go in this like
nice kind gentle direction but I think
we have to consider the other
possibilities will return that's only to
get something in article ii the image of
the president with those steel workers
telling their stories about companies
that are slowing down shutting down
losing work that politically works for
this president certainly in western
Pennsylvania where they're about to have
a special election Pennsylvania 18 that
is coming Tuesday and there's a lot of
steel mills and of course economically
this is kind of a nun squabble circle
you know this thing can either have its
effect and save those steel jobs you're
talking about or it can be acceptable to
our allies it can't be it can't really
be
both and so what I think the president
is set up here is this funny kind of
Lobby Oh Rama in Washington where
everybody and they're paid hired guns
here in Washington are gonna suddenly
bombard the bureaucracy Bob light Heiser
in particular with their plea for some
kind of a carve out in this thing and
then you if any of them get it the
question will be will does is there
anything left of the protection that
he's talking about that's so important
so it's actually when you really think
about it it's he has in mind and the
criteria Bret that he was offering these
countries were very vaguely stated well
if they do a little more on military if
they treat us fairly so if there were
going to be any carve outs if this thing
is going to be turned into Swiss cheese
as john roberts said the bush tariffs
were it will be after a long drawn-out
process that has a lot of politics
involved in it all right here is the
president essentially saying goodbye to
his advisor Gary Cohen today it's gonna
go out and make another couple of
hundred million and then then he's gonna
maybe come back might come back right
we'll be here absolutely another seven
years hopefully and that's a long time
but I have a feeling you'll be back I
don't know if I can put him in the same
position though he's not quite as strong
are those tariffs as we want them that's
when I'll just call him a globalist
couple of times as well it was a nice
light-hearted moment I'm glad to see
that Gary Cohen is leaving the White
House on good terms he's certainly not
getting the Steve banning treatment and
the intrigue about what he will do if he
comes back is interesting as New York
Times reported maybe he's going to be
the next chief of staff inside skinny
I'm who's up for that position
you mean the chief of staff position no
any see she here a nice is a name that
is being thrown around a lot she's a
senior official on the National Economic
Council Gary Cohen is advocating for her
but so are senior people on Capitol Hill
she's definitely in the mix but there's
others as well we've reported Kevin
washe who was in the running for Fed
chair is a name that Trump's talking
about
but he's still spitballing Larry Kudlow
he I haven't heard his name as much it's
been in the media ether but I haven't
actually heard from you know people
inside that he's really at the top of
their